wir zeigen ihnen bilder jetzt die uns
ganz besonders bewegen mit diesen
bildern zurück hierbei bild live sind
bilder aus der grenzregion von belarus
nach polen von der grenze dort wo
diktator lukaschenko hunderte tausende
hinschickt an die grenze an den zaun zur
eu und dort aktuell drängen eben
tausende rein nach polen das sind ganz
frische bilder genau von dort also immer
mehr menschen ein massenansturm kann man
aktuell sagen auf die eu auf die grenze
nach polen die menschen die dort zu
großen teilen im moment noch ausharren
vor dem zaun also vor der europäischen
union und rein wollen polen will die
grenze sichern dort aber dabei schauen
wir zu wie diese menschen aus haren an
der grenze und eben rein wollen in die
europäische union ein neues
flüchtlingsdrama direkt vor unserer tür
und darüber wollen wir sprechen jetzt
hier im bild live studio mit unserem
chefreporter peter tiede peter wenn du
diese bilder sie ist auch luftaufnahmen
aktuell aus dem grenzgebiet belarus
polen das sind bilder wie wir sie von
215 im kopf haben und nie wieder sehen
wollten es gab eine ähnliche situation
ist nicht vergleichbar bei eine ähnliche
situation rein von den bildern her als
am dritten september am dritten vierten
september 2015 sich flüchtlinge auf den
weg gemacht haben aus der ungarischen
hauptstadt wo sie gegen campiert haben
hin zur österreichischen grenze damals
haben deutschland und österreich
entschieden die grenze zu öffnen das war
quasi der beginn der flüchtlingskrise
damals und des stroms diese bilder sind
sind wir als bilder fallen fallen gleich
bei hier man muss es so hart sagen wird
europa angegriffen die flüchtlinge
werden missbraucht als waffe gegen uns
alexander lukaschenko hat das ganz klare
ausgegebene ziel europa zu stabilisieren
polen und sein ziel ist natürlich
deutschland weil er weiß wo die
flüchtlinge hinwollen die werden auch
quasi herangeholt mit dem ziel sie nach
deutschland zu schicken die leute wollen
da hin und hier sehen wir bilder das ist
etwa 280 kilometer von uns entfernt an
der grenze kurz vor kurz vor der grenze
zu polen das ist großes waldgebiet als
ein riesengroßer nationalpark
grasen bison herden das
welterbe eigentlich und dort werden die
flüchtlinge raus gekarrt und es gibt
bilder auch wir sehen hier sind die
flüchtlinge noch an der autobahn man
sieht auch die ganzen schilder hier ist
hier sieht man dass es exakt 280
kilometer vom minister kommt gleich
rechts ein verkehrsschild und da sieht
man den strom der flüchtlinge und man
muss sich fragen wie kommen sie da
eigentlich in 280 kilometer sind die
nicht zu fuß gelaufen sind dahin gekarrt
worden jetzt rechts fährt gerade das
steht zwar bei 280 kilometer nach minsk
und das sind sie sogar zusammen da sind
aufnahmen aus polen aus einem
hubschrauber der vermutlich vom
polnischen grenzschutz wir sehen unten
polen und oben das ist weißrussland wir
haben hunderte ja wirklich mehr als 1000
flüchtlinge die sich allein in diesem
einen wald gebiet aufhalten also zeigt
nochmal genau das will jetzt hier das
ist genau die grenze also rein in die
europäische union sei das war ja das
sind 210 oder einen zaun ist so ist
durch ist durchbrochen der ist hinter
dem flüchtling quasi dahin sieht man
einen weißrussischen postenweg man sieht
unten stehen die polnischen grenze an
unten sieht man im polnischen kosten weg
davon die patrouillen lang oben sieht
man hält jetzt links auftauchend einen
dann den weißrussischen postenweg es
gibt viele aufnahmen die zeigen dass
auch weißrussischer seite der zaun
aufgeschnitten worden ist und dass sie
jetzt vor dem polnischen zaun stehen die
große frage ist jetzt natürlich wie
reagiert polen in warschau tag zur
stunde der krisenstab man man weiß nicht
genau was dort jetzt passieren wird aber
polen hat auch diese aufnahmen gibt es
massiv truppen verlegt an die grenze hat
den grenzschutz dort verstärkt auch mit
militär es herrscht und ohnehin
ausnahmezustand ist ist der erklärt von
für eine ganze region das hat auch zur
folge dass journalisten in das gebiet
nicht hinein können also das ist auch
gesperrt am ersten oktober ist der ist
ausnahmezustand für die grenzregion noch
mal um 60 tage verlängert wurde und hier
sieht man das sind die wälder von denen
ich gerade gesprochen habe das ist ein
großer nationalpark auf beiden seiten
der grenze und da campieren jetzt
hunderte flüchtlinge mehr als 1000
sollen es allein in der region nördlich
von brest sein und in ganz - das
twittert jetzt der- oder in ganzen
weißrussland das wetter der sprecher der
exil präsidentin tier an oskar sollte es
zwischen 10 und zwischen 20.000
migranten geben es gibt bilder aus minsk
wo die in den u-bahnhöfen schlafen wo
sie quasi märkte stürmen um sich
winterklamotten kaufen zu können weil
sie das nicht gewohnt sind die wird
eingeflogen die wehren aus dem irak
eingeflogen aus der mascus eingriff
eingeflogen wirklich mit einem einzigen
ziel die europäische union anzugreifen
polen in verlegenheit zu bringen und
wahrscheinlich auch zu provozieren das
an der grenze geschossen wird denn wenn
jetzt hunderte oder gar tausende
flüchtlinge über die grenze kommen dann
ist die frage wie reagiert polen dann
werden warnschüsse abgegeben werden das
ist das ist gegeben das ist auch nicht
verboten wir haben ähnliche bilder
gesehen vor etwa einem jahr und vor
einem dreiviertel jahr von der grenze
türkei griechenland am fluss evros da
haben damals auf der türkischen seite
steht das kommando ausgegeben die grenze
ist auf das tor ist auf
flüchtlinge losgestürmt und damals ist
geschossen worden es gab einen toten
aber das gehörte mit dazu man darf seine
grenze tatsächlich auch verteidigen und
es findet ein angriff wir können jetzt
wirklich nur hoffen dass dort niemand zu
tode kommt das nicht auf die menschen
geschossen werden die ja von beiden die
ja wirklich missbraucht werden von lukas
schenkel und auch von moskau nichts was
lukas schenkel macht macht er ohne
moskau kann er auch nicht machen er muss
auch seine eigene fluglinie fliegt nicht
mehr die migranten ein das passiert über
moskau über istanbul und wir können nur
hoffen dass polen eine lösung einfällt
dass da irgendetwas geschieht ohne dass
menschen wirklich in lebensgefahr kommt
man muss einfach so sagen lukas schenkel
schießt mit menschen auf die europäische
union das ist eine schreckliche
situation für die menschen die ihnen
jetzt auch hoffnungen gemacht wird ja da
wird er mit falschen hoffnungen gespielt
sie werden ja mehr oder weniger zum
politischen pingpong ball wenn man es
einmal mit peter wie konnte es überhaupt
so weit kommen nimmt uns mit in die
hintergründe dass wir heute jetzt
verseuchen schockierenden bildern sitzen
wo menschen sich hoffnungen machen und
missbraucht werden norbert röttgen hat
das genauso auch gesagt er gesagt
flüchtlinge werden als waffe missbraucht
ja und was braucht man eine eine waffe
also wann wann benutzt man eine waffe
wenn man jemanden angreift wenn man
krieg führt und es gibt einen hybriden
krieg gegen den westen hier sehen wir
den speed von norbert röttgen
lukaschenko benutzt flüchtlinge als
waffe um die europäer für ihre
solidarität mit dem die russen zu
bestrafen das ist staatlich gelenkter
menschenhandel diese menschen stammen
aus ländern die viel geld von der eu
erhalten sie müssen die flügel daniela
ryf einstellen das ist auch eine ganz
klare warnung an die länder die jetzt
dafür sorgen dass lukaschenko seine
flugzeuge voll machen kann damit es auch
die türkei gemeint weil auch aus
istanbul comcom flüge aber auf deine
frage zurück wie konnte es dazu kommen
warum macht lukas schenkel dass wir
haben vor mehr als einem jahr im august
vorigen jahres gab es die wahl in
weißrussland die lukaschenko krachend
verloren hat da gab es die frei gewählte
eigentliche präsidentin der allofs kaya
die ist im exil die hat er hinaus
passiert es gab massenproteste daraufhin
hat die europäische union mit sanktionen
reagiert mit relativ harten sanktionen
und dann kam es dazu dass ein flug von
kiew aus
der ukraine nach oben um ins baltikum
gegen und da saß ein journalist rinne da
saß ein gegner lukaschenko stone ein
kritiker und diese ryanair maschine ist
über weißrussischen luftraum zur landung
gezwungen worden der mann ist quasi aus
dem flugzeug heraus geholt und in den
kerkern von lukas schenkel verschwunden
daraufhin hat die europäische union
beschlossen dass der luftraum über
weißrussland für maschinen gesperrt wird
also wer über weißrussland fliegt darf
nicht in die europäische union fliegen
darf hier nicht landen und da damals hat
nur geschenke angekündigt sollte das
wirklich so kommen dann werde ich dann
werde ich flüchtlinge nach europa
schicken das ist eine altbekannte taktik
die hat ja sowjet blog die hatte
ostblock schon immer angewandt seit
jahrzehnten so zuletzt 1908 1988 so lang
ist er schon vor über 30 jahren da haben
moskau und die ddr flüchtlingen nach
berlin-schönefeld geflogen und haben die
gezielt nach westberlin rübergeschickt
zum nicht schon wie sind hier sehen wir
wieder bilder also das soll deutschland
das soll die europäische union de
stabilisieren und tatsächlich wird es ja
gewaltige diskussionen auslösen
diese bilder sie ganz frisch
reingekommen sind videos aus dem belarus
polnischen grenzgebiet dort und wir
haben gerade auch geschrieben das ist
die grenze nach polen aber das ist in
wahrheit die grenze nach deutschland
denn die leute wollen ja nicht in polen
bleiben ganz viele von denen die
allermeisten wollen weiter ziehen nach
deutschland das heißt jetzt einmal um zu
sprechen zu kommen auf die diskussionen
die das hierzulande auslöst peter ja
fast verzweifelte reaktion von norbert
röttgen ein appell diese flüge
einzustellen ein appell auch an diktator
lukaschenko der den aber ja gar nicht
hören würde in der willi genau diese
bilder und die diskussion wie gehen wir
mit diesen menschen jetzt um die stehen
direkt vor der tür in die eu wir können
die bilder nochmal zeigen vor allen
dingen aus der luft die stehen direkt
vor unserer tür und wir wollen den zaun
dicht halten und wollen sagen bleibt
draußen und müssen uns möglicherweise in
den nächsten stunden noch viel
dramatischere bilder da direkt vom zaun
aus anschauen das ist moralische
erpressung wir sollen moralisch erpresst
werden was man in moskau und in und in
minsk weiß ist dass wir moralisch
handeln dass wir auch moralischen
standard haben und dass wir bei allen
gesetzen die bei uns gelten mögen dann
am ende des tages doch auf
menschlichkeit setzen und da genau damit
sollen wir erpresst werden dass wir
sagen wir können doch mütter und kinder
nicht zurückschicken wir können doch
mütter und kinder nicht im ungewissen
lassen wir können nicht auf mütter und
kinder mit gewalt reagieren die wahrheit
ist die harte wahrheit ist eigentlich
müssten wir es eigentlich müssten wir es
und dann kommt die moral und dann sind
wir im dilemma genau in dieses dilemma
sollen wir hineingestürzt werden und
eigentlich müssten wir hart reagieren
wenn so hart wie es ist und so brutal
wie es ist die leute wollen alle aus
einem landhaus oder wollen etwas suchen
etwas bei uns aber illegale migration
illegaler grenzübertritt ist verboten
und eigentlich müssen wir uns
durchsetzen und es ist lukaschenkos
problem wenn er die leute nicht wieder
zurück kriegt jedes schicksal ist
dramatisch jedes schicksal ist für sich
genommen schlimm aber insgesamt muss
eigentlich geltend dass wir die grenzen
schützen und dass wir uns nicht
dauerhaft erpressen lassen wenn wir
dieses tor aufmachen dann kriegen wir es
nicht mehr zu das hat auch 2015 gezeigt
wenn einmal der erfolg da ist einmal ein
massen durchbruch da ist dann entsteht
eine sogwirkung dann haben die schleuser
eine geschichte die sie erzählen können
dann haben sie bilder die sie zeigen
können sieht er wie schaffen es ihr
kommt nach deutschland ihr kommt nach
europa das ist das dilemma in dem wir
uns schlicht und ergreifend jetzt
befinden es gab so was muss denn jetzt
passieren jetzt befinden wir uns ja
gerade in deutschland auch in so einer
übergangsphase die alte regierung und
nicht richtig weg die neue noch nicht
richtig da und jetzt passiert da ist das
ist zwar noch an der grenze zu polen
aber wir geben ja gerade sagte das ist
ja die eu grenze also das ist ja ein
ganz kurzer weg dann nach deutschland
rüber was muss passieren um das in den
griff zu bekommen und ich denke dabei
auch an die menschen die missbraucht
werden wir sagen als ja als ping pong
ball
den hoffnungen gemacht werden und die
jetzt in diesem bitterkalten wäldern
stehen das ist natürlich ein absolutes
dilemma ist auch rechtlich ein richtiges
schlimmes dilemma weil wenn die leute
drüben sind und asyl rufen dann müssen
wir ihnen ein asylverfahren bieten dann
müssen sie zumindest erst einmal muss
geprüft werden müssen sie aufgenommen
werden
man kann ein bisschen bis zum bestimmten
punkt kann man sich noch zurück schieben
aber wenn da jetzt hunderte über die
grenze kommen wird polen die nicht
zurückschieben können wir müssen dann
mit polen zusammen das ist schwierig
auch wenn die regierung in polen gerade
keiner wirklich einfach ist weil es
wirklich hart ist und weil sie auch zum
teil brutal jetzt schon reagiert haben
auf die flüchtlinge die haben wirklich
schwer verletzte leute einfach wieder
einfach wieder ausgesetzt und dann muss
man gucken ob man in polen als eu als
europäische union bewussten nicht nur
als deutschland das ist nicht nur eine
sache zwischen uns und polen sondern
wirklich eine sache der eu da muss man
da schnellstmöglich lager machen in
denen dann die verfahren durchgeführt
wird und dann muss man aber auch so hart
sein und die leute die keinen anspruch
auf asyl haben direkt wieder aus fliegen
wie david lasar